اما طبعا نحن في مرحله من مراحل عمليه
مغادره
رعايه ايران الذين قدموا ابرار السفينه
سعوديه اليوم من بورسودان الى جده طبعا هم
يغادرون الان عبر الطائره
ايرانيه من قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
في مدينه جده طبعا هذه هي اللحظات الاولى
الان لمقادره هذا
الوفد وهم او مكونون من اثنين
شخصا قدمه اليوم على سفينه امانه السعوديه
طبعا هم وصلوا وتم انهاء اجراءاتهم كباقي
اجراءات
الرعايه الاخرين طائره ايرباص 320 ايرانيه
سوف تقوم
بعملها هؤلاء الرعايه باتجاه طهران طبعا
لعلها من الرحلات الطويله او الرحلات التي
تسمى في رحلات طارئه التي تصل الطائره
ايرانيه وبعد ذلك تغادر من هنا من قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه ولعل هذه الطفله هي
سعيده ايضا
عند بعد ان اخذت حلوى ورد وهي تقوم
بها نحو بلادها بعد
وصلت الى بر الامان الى مدينه جده عبر
السفينه امانه طبعا انهاء الاجراءات وكذلك
عمليه مواصله
الاهتمام بالرعايه كباقي الرعايه الاخرين
الذين يتم اجناؤهم الى مدينه جده بتاكيد
في هذه الاجواء هاني الان تتابع عمليات
الاجلاء المستمره نحن امام ربما
امر مختلف هذه المره هؤلاء رعايه ايرانيين
ونحن نتابع تصريحات التي كانت تتوالى منها
هؤلاء الرعايه انهم لم يكنوا يتوقعون ان
تتم المغادره من السعوديه هل يمكن ان تصف
لنا الاجواء لديك في هذا الامر تحديدا
حقيقه الامر نحن اجرينا لقاء مع بعض روايا
ايران والذين يتحدثوا انهم تفاجئوا
بحسن الضيافه والكرم لم يتوقعوا بان
يشاهدوا هذا التعامل
اخر قد قرا عن السعوديه وعن
التنمويه التي تعيش فيها هناك ايضا من قال
نحن
فعلا هناك السفاره السعوديه في الخرطوم
والخارجيه السعوديه قد ساعدتهم كثيرا في
بورسودان بعد وصولهم طبعا هناك طلب من
الخارجيه الايرانيه الى الخارجيه السعوديه
في وقت السابق بان تقوم بمساعده
رعاياها ان تقوم بمساعده راياها الى
السعوديه واجبارهم بسلام وامان وهاهم
اليوم يصلون الى جده وبعد ذلك الان يصلون
الى قاعده الملك
والان هم على
[موسيقى]
سعودهم وبعد ذلك سوف تغ
ادر الخاص المؤد لذلك سوف يجري لقاء مع
سعاده
انها الهوى مباشره نحو على العربيه كيف
رايتم اولا الاجراءات التي قامت بها
السعوديه اليوم الحمد لله جدا جيد
الاوسط بدوري من دار السعودي
[موسيقى]
ين عند وصولهم وكذلك كما اثنى على جهود
السعوديه والخدمات المقدمه سواء من الجهات
الحكوميه او كذلك من الجهات الامنيه التي
قامت برعايه مواطن رايه ايران حتى صعودهم
على هذه
[موسيقى]
الطاقه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات